tiens tard qu'aura sera une photo du csa
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
l on vient et alors est ce que serra
sera obsèques le csii moi c'est une
grande histoire une histoire à trois
millions dont vous avez fait beaucoup de
progrès dans la maîtrise de votre
antenne mais je ne pouvais tout aussi
drôle tout en étant respectueux donc
bravo pour ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que alors après il ya eu 7 7
cette affaire malheureuse l'an dernier
j'étais venu vous voir
j'étais venu en vélo parce que j'en ai
place pratiquement à partir de mars vous
déplaît à expliquer pourquoi vous étiez
venu en vélo c'est pas du tout parce que
vous êtes écolo c'est parce que vous
vouliez que les caméras vous voir mais
n'ont pas dit
[Applaudissements]
la faute d'apple d'avoir un petit peu
les coulisses de cette entrevue parce
qu'évidemment on connaît que la face
visible vers saint cyr il nous a raconté
une certaine version supporte que j'ai
pas raconter alors que vous l'avez que
vous l'aviez reçu extrêmement
cordialement et que l'entretien avait
été courtois mais on en n'a pas su plus
est ce que vous pourriez dévoilé deux
trois petites choses de cette entrevue
je reçus ou convoqué non je ne
convainquent personne ne sait pas
pourquoi les gens pensent qu'ils ont vu
n'est qu'on veut enfin je suis pas
proviseur du lycée a serré la vis moi
j'avais 18 ans j'avais toujours jeune et
entités cordialement il a eu la
gentillesse de venir en vélo et ont fait
parler franchement on a parlé voilà de
l'homophobie on a parlé d' égalité
femmes hommes de la culture du viol je
vous avais donné mon livre sur la
culture josiane j'en ai amené un pour
chacun d'entre eux seraient là et je
voulais aussi les chiffres des
inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes en france et hollande du tour de
france de l'égalité femmes hommes qui
est la plus grande consultation
citoyenne jamais organisé par un
gouvernement qui vient de se terminer sa
condition mais elle s'est très bien
passé les 5000 personnes
bravo vous allez revenir génial avec les
deux les deux là j'ai des deux premières
places on va vous les distribuer
pendant la pause dont deux secondes
merci mais je fêterai de l'impasse et la
preuve il est revenu je vais faire des
lasagnes
mais j'ai mangé ensemble
il y a
je crois que ça se passe bien serré
d'entre nous non
[Applaudissements]